since democrats have been quarantining
for two years they have no idea what's
going on outside no idea what real
americans are feeling that's what
happens when you stay inside afraid of
crowds and check twitter all day
so it took a pollster to break the news
to him that everybody hates their woke
nonsense even democrat voters and
they're about to get annihilated in
november
so now the party's panicking joe biden
isn't respected brand new polling shows
him at 37 percent approval
biden didn't shut down the virus
everybody got it inflation's painful and
the president isn't doing a thing about
it
two obama officials
are now telling biden you better get it
together
in a new york times article former obama
guy steve ratner says biden's excuse for
inflation is dishonest
and david axelrod says it's time for the
president to grow up and be a little
more humble
but the destruction of the democratic
party stretches far beyond joe biden
and for once
msnbc gets something right
the democrats have got to step away from
the super wokeness i mean san francisco
really tells what's going on here you've
got three school board members that were
voted out by 70 because they're focusing
on things like changing the name of
schools abraham lincoln on a school
george washington on the school this is
not what voters care about so you need
to step away from super wokeness fastest
way to end a culture war is lose it and
that's what the democrats should do
surrender
back the blue scrap crt and just start
acting normal around children again
it's all hands on deck in the media they
see the landslide coming even the
associated press says the brand is so
toxic
dems fear extinction in rural u.s
the democratic party's losing voters
faster than cnn is losing viewers i know
that fast
so apparently it's time for a costume
change
democrats are running as republicans
that's how bad this is
they don't even care they want to hold
on to power that badly
some suddenly democrats want to reopen
schools and get rid of masks and nancy
pelosi is the law and order candidate
there's some issues that we ask police
to do like mental health issues or
policing in schools and all the rest
that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around corey
bush congresswoman from missouri is
saying it's time to defund the police
he's sticking by that with all the
respect in the world for court push that
is not the position of the democratic
party
community safety
to protect and defend in every way is
our oath of office
to fund the police is dead
defund the police is dead because it
killed people
and those body bags lie at the doorstep
of the democratic party
it's obvious the democrats are failing
the exam so they're just cheating and
stealing the answers from republicans
it's that simple
the left is even calling
for tax cuts
at this point democrats might want to
finish the wall
we can only dream
but the entire party isn't on board with
this pivot
some didn't get the memo for example
some are blaming the wacky san francisco
school board recall
on white supremacy
calling freedom
a code word for racist yeah
freedom is racist
which means slavery
isn't racist
it's all very confusing
and aoc continues to aoc
he fought tooth and nail for the
inclusion of undocumented people in uh
in relief packages stimulus checks
fema assistance and we've actually
helped huge amounts of undocumented
families in our district get federal
relief
that many others were trying to lock
them out of
welfare for illegals
i think i know what the memo said about
that
so the question is will the party be
able to pull off this costume change in
time for the midterms or will the loud
mouths on the left ruin it and get the
party stuck in awoke quagmire
joining me now to respond to victor
davis hanson senior fellow at the hoover
institution
the democratic party could be extinct
like the dinosaurs potentially vdh
i mean
is this even possible
i well they're at the end of the hallway
and there's only three doors out jesse
you and you outlined it and they've got
a cognitively impaired president who's
obnoxious and mean-spirited and they
have issues that are pulling less than
his 37 percent so option one is as you
say
they can double down and they can say
you know what we would rather be
wrong with marks and socialism than
right with moderation we're glorious
revolutionaries we're going to double
down and we're going to go for the go
for broke and then they can say you know
what there's a door b we can get dirty
and mean we can get the zuckerbergs in
the silicon valley spend another 419
million dollars target precincts go out
get the january 6 back up we can go
after donald trump we can get all this
money we can file lawsuits they can do
that the tactics the methodology route
or they can do as you say they can do
the dick morris 1995 96
remake of bill clinton and suddenly
we'll hear about knight basketball and
school uniforms 100 000 police officers
but the problem with the third is that
these people are not democrats they're
revolutionaries and what the rational
logical answer is sitting there for
everybody to see doesn't mean they're
going to take it they're emotional and
they would rather begin they would
better be wrong and pure than right and
moderate and so i don't think that i
don't think they're going to do and they
have another problem with being moderate
the republican party today isn't the
republican party in the 90s it's a
populist nationalist party that is
appealing to the middle class more than
the very wealthy the democrats are very
wealthy and the very poor but this party
is starting to transcend race and
replace it with class middle class
concerns so they don't have a lock hold
on hispanics or african-american males
or asians as they used to
i think that they have a problem so i
think they're going to
select door a and go down to gloria's
defeat as as revolutionary okay so
you're saying they're gonna go for broke
they're not gonna buy their way out
they're not gonna lie their way out
they're gonna go woke uh going for broke
yeah uh do you see the race card playing
a factor in the midterm elections cause
that's been so effective the gender card
the race card i mean that is their bread
and butter but with inflation
and and gas prices and crime affecting
broad swaths of the population rich poor
you know black white everybody
is that is that going to play
i don't know if it's going to play
i think they're going to lose whatever
of the three alternatives they take but
doesn't mean that they won't take the
radical one i think they would rather
lose and be pure so they're going to
talk about racism transgenderism sexism
okay inequality diversity all the way
down and if they lose they're going to
say you know what we had a glorious two
years of a progressive left-wing
congress
and you know
that's what they're going to do
a selfish part of me wants them to take
dorae because i know they'll go down in
flames but it's not the patriotic thing
to think but maybe it's
maybe i'm just you know
maybe i'm just a shallow person all
right vdh
thank you as always for your expertise
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else